defence sources have told sky news the
raf has effectively paused making job
offers to white male recruits to meet
what have been described as impossible
diversity targets let's go live to
westminster speak to our political
correspondent murray o'rourke mari tell
us more
so this is a really interesting story
deborah haynes has actually discovered
it at skyler she's a security and
defense editor and as far as they know
the head of recruitment for the raf has
actually resigned in protest about these
so-called impossible diversity targets
and as you said essentially they're
saying it's effectively a kind of pause
on recruitment on white male recruits
participants focus on women female
recruits and also ethnic minority
recruits as well now this is according
to defense sources so we obviously are
protecting those identities
but it's really interesting because
these sources have told us that they
think uh the head of the raf who is air
chief marshal sir mike wigston is
essentially willing to compromise uk
security at a time of growing threats
from russia and from china and the like
now we know that the raf have a
spokesperson has actually given us a
reply they've denied these allegations
and they said there is no
pause for royal air force recruitment
and no new policy with regards to
meeting in-year recruitment requirements
they also went on to say that the royal
air force commanders will not shy away
from the challenges we face building a
service that attracts recruits from
talent of every part of the uk workforce
but this is obviously a really difficult
situation for the raf they are obviously
under pressure to achieve those
diversity targets and recruit lots of
people from different backgrounds and
obviously more women it's a very male
dominated area but also it means that
potentially they're now being accused of
actually compromising the uk safety the
nation's safety to achieve these targets
that's not going to sound good going to
go down very well now i wish you soon as
one of the current candidates for the
tory leadership he has actually uh
issued a statement a rishi sunak uh
spokesperson says the only thing that
should matter in recruitment is the
content of your character not your sex
or the color of your skin that the
ministry of defense would allow
britain's security to potentially be put
at risk
by a drive for so-called diversity is
not only disgraceful but it's dangerous
now we haven't heard from liz trust on
this but i'm expecting to see that this
story this scoop by deborah haynes is
going to end up being used as
arsenal in the tory leadership race both
candidates are attempting to kind of
wage this war on woke and this is just
another kind of piece of ammunition they
can use to try and destroy or discredit
what they would call the woke
agenda okay murray in westminster thank
you